la planche à voile a le vent en poupe en
france un million de véliplanchistes
dont environ 10000 en aquitaine et cette
année on pense atteindre le nom de
200000 planche vendue le support et
trouver maintenant engager tease sur le
marché apparaît le kata surf inspiré du
catamaran pour ceux qui n'aiment pas la
solitude
il y a le tandem et le fin du fin pour
les sportifs une sorte de formule 1 avec
sept planches 12 kg 3 mètres de long
dont on peut se servir avec un vent de
force 4 minimum actuellement pas de
réglementation technique de sécurité
pour la planche à voile le ministère des
transports vient de le répéter cela dit
il est bon que le vide planchistes
prennent certaines précautions déjà au
niveau du transport en voiture car les
ennuis peuvent déjà commencer là avant
que vous ne soyez sur votre plan alors
quelles sont les motivations de ceux qui
pratiquent ce sport est justement
l'avantagent de la planche à voile c'est
un sport qui est à la portée de tous on
peut trouver l'harmonie à travers la
nature et notamment dans les vagues et
dans la mer la groupie l'équivalent
féminin du surfeur hawaiien moyen est
une variété de poisson pilote
sans elle le funboard ne serait pas ce
qu'il est il lui manquerait quelque
chose d'essentiel la groupie a aussi un
look plutôt bien étudié et à nulle autre
comparable
la groupie n'a des yeux bleus que pour
robby naish leroy robbie le king de
hawaii le meilleur fun border du monde
le tueur des vagues elle qui n'est
jamais monté sur une planche elle en
rêve mais robbie est inaccessible